the article featured the Sea Islands
because many were known there to live
much as their ancestors of a century ago
had lived so this one immediately seems
strange because they're saying the
article featured the sea islands because
many were known so when they're saying
feature the Sea Islands because many
were known I I'm thinking that when
they're saying many were known I think
they're talking about the Sea Islands
because that's what the article was
featured on because many were known
there to live much as their ansible
Islands don't live much as their
ancestors and it's so the way this reads
it sounds like you know the article was
talking about Sea Islands because many
of the sea islands were known to live
like the sea islands ancestors on this
the way their ancestors well Islands
don't have ancestors at least in the way
that we traditionally think about it so
this is just badly free so I'm going to
rule it out as it is so I'm going to
rule out choice a which is the kind of
as it is so they're really talking about
where the residents were known to live
as their ancestor so we have to be a
little bit more specific here the
article featured the Sea Islands because
they were known for living well once
again they it's not the Sea Islands
we're really talking about the the
residents the people of the sea islands
so I'm going to rule this one out as
well the article featured the Sea
Islands because many of the people there
were known to live much as their
ancestors of a century ago had lived
well at least this one's conveying the
right the right impression there you
know it's making it clear we're not
talking about the Sea Islands ancestors
or the Sea Islands living like their
answers we're talking about the people
who are known to live there live like
their ancestors so this one is feeling
this one is feeling pretty good let's
try the other choices the article
featured the Sea Islands because of the
many people they were living there they
were they were there living much as
their ancestors of a century ago had
lived so so once again you have this
common here this is convoluted and it's
also not completely clear the article
featured the Sea Islands because of the
many people they were
living this makes it sounds like like
the sea islands are somehow a subset of
the many people and still that they're
talking about the sea the sea islands
themselves were living like their answer
so once again doesn't doesn't make sense
or at least it's confusing so I'm going
to rule that one out the article
featured the Sea Islands because of
knowing that many people lived there
much as their ancestors of a century ago
had lived well he with this one well
this one has all sorts of problems if
you said because of knowing that many
people lived there at much as their
ancestors of a century ago had lived it
leaves you hanging well what was because
of knowing that many people have lived
there so it leaves you hanging and then
and then it's also just convoluted
because of knowing of knowing that many
people had lived there much as their
ancestors you know because we know this
fact something is going to be there they
didn't even tell us what is because of
knowing so I'm just going to did this
one is also really really really
restrained so definitely like see the
article featured the Sea Islands because
many of the people there were known to
live much as their ancestors of a
century ago had lid yeah that's nice and
understandable